well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see then what is
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire welcome i know
you're with us until midnight more from
you in just a moment first the front
pages then the telegraph leads with the
arrest of a british person working as a
security guard at the british embassy in
berlin on charges that he spied for
russia
russia spy soul secret is the headline
for the daily mirror
meanwhile a return to the dark ages is
how the metro describes the plight of
afghans under threat from a resurgent
taliban
councils face crisis as care referrals
and mental health cases amongst children
saw that's a garden exclusive they say
the financial times reports that the
biden administration is asking opec to
increase oil production to try to drive
down petrol prices so they don't hinder
an economic recovery
one more papers due in we will take a
look at them as they emerge but in the
meantime let's get the thoughts of
andrew and kevin on one of the main
stories for the newspapers andrew um
this embassy security alert in berlin i
mean it's back to the bad old days isn't
it
yeah it's like the cold war all over
again um spies and russia
and of course it's um a british
contractor has been arrested in the
embassy in germany accused of passing
secrets to russian operatives in berlin
in return for cash
um you you imagine you imagine these
days a lot of the spying is done
by by cyber warfare the internet but
actually it appears if these reports are
true and we don't know if they are um
that um secrets were handed over and
that sort of stuff you expect from
michael kane in some of those great
films uh behind the berlin wall um it's
of course comes at a delicate time
between britain and russia germany and
russia because of the
tension caused by the disgraceful way
the russians have treated that
opposition leader navalny who was beaten
up and poisoned and is in prison um and
this is going to cause problems with
more attention for germany and russia
russia could be making this up of course
um but the fact is they spy on us and we
spy on them and we know that we probably
spy on the germans as well and they
probably spy on us but it's just a bit
unusual now
for allegedly a brit to be caught in the
act if in fact he has been we're not
allowed to name him other than to call
him david s it all adds to the intrigue
absolutely it does and many people have
suggested today that berlin is still a
hub as it was back when the uh when the
city was split with east germany but if
you think about russia as a bad actor in
recent years the list is long as it not
you know ukraine crimea
election tampering salisbury poisoning
you mentioned alexia navalny as well um
how should the world be viewing mr putin
and uh and russia kevin
yeah of course their biggest prize was
probably the election of donald trump's
uh president in the u.s
usa look they're very the various
uh putin is uh is it he's a new czar
he's an authoritarian an authoritarian
nationalist it's interesting that the
politicians who admire and praise the
russians now are on the right of
politics no longer on the left because
it isn't uh a communist a communist
country you've got to be very wary of
russia but what would be unusual i think
anna is if there's a david s uh 57 the
private contractor uh who's accused of
spying is actually a security guard
because most of the the spies in british
history for the russians tended to be um
you know private school boys uh uh quite
privileged and and posh uh phil b
burgess maclean blunt
that lot but as andrew says they spy on
us we spy on them um let the americans
it was revealed in documentary
spying on um on angela merkel um a very
senior british cabinet minister once
told me that he'd been warned by his
french counterpart to be careful what he
said on his mobile phone because the
french monitored that everybody is
spying on everybody but it's a pretty
successful security operation between
the germans and it's believed to be the
british security services to pick up the
uh the alleged spy uh who is accused of
handing over documents for funny so he
may not have had real access to top
secrets but you've just got to assume
that everybody is spying on everybody
else because everybody seems to be
spying on everybody else i don't think
this is the start of a new coal it's
been going on for some time as we saw
with the the salisbury
uh poisonings and what what you say uh
about uh the ukraine uh shooting down of
an airliner and so on it's all it's all
pretty grim and nasty and
the west britain and other countries are
still grappling on how do you deal
with putin and his cronies yes and uh
telegraph pointing out details of the
information he is alleged to have passed
to russian intelligence have not been
made public so we watch this space don't
we but uh let's move on to the metro
leading on the plight of afghans fleeing
the taliban
you know reports as we might have come
to expect i mean i presume you know the
uk and us watch and wait but but horror
for people this is going backwards isn't
it andrew
look it's horrible um but what's the
answer and the moment trump announced he
was withdrawing the troops from the
united states the british presence was
pretty much pointless uh and um biden
felt he had to carry on with the the
trump policy so those american troops
are pulling out inevitably the taliban
al-qaeda are going to step into the
vacuum and um nine of i think
afghanistan's 54 capitals have already
fallen the sad part is to hear that
people are fleeing to kabul the capital
and yet there are reports now that kabul
could fall within 30 to 90 days it's a
complete diplomatic disaster it's a
humanitarian catastrophe
um there are all sorts of people saying
we should go back in well
who which british troops do we want to
put in there i'd ask this question to
tony blair he's watching what did this
war really achieve 454 british service
men and women killed hundreds more have
suffered life-shattering injuries 40
billion pounds down the drain and within
weeks of leaving the taliban are going
to be back in control and even the
progress made in letting girls go to
school that will all stop because
they'll turn the clock back to
pre-victorian england
and women will be third-rate citizens
again the whole thing is a complete
it's a disaster from start to finish and
i can't really see what britain's
supposed to do about it but i certainly
don't think we should be sending our
troops back in there any time soon
because history tells you nobody ever
conquers in afghanistan
well pre-medieval times you know
according to to the metro uh the costs
you you outlined there uh just the uk
not to mention the us and that's the
problem that biden had pointing out that
thousands of u.s soldiers lost their
lives fighting uh the uk obviously
helmund gagar under pressure um kabul
under pressure 20 years um of what i
mean it's extremely difficult isn't it
uh for the afghan government who feel
abandoned they've lost you know medivac
they've lost all of the backup logistics
and intelligence that comes with with
foreign forces on the ground and never
mind trying to fight for themselves then
kevin
yeah i went to afghanistan
about 10 years ago
and one of the problems is
british troops would be sent in on a
rotation they might be there maximum six
months and they'd be out again but these
it's a society there in afghanistan
where families and clans tend to stay in
the same place they just saw people
coming in going out and the the taliban
was never actually defeated it would
just melt away at times and there is
it's a humanitarian disaster they're
absolutely barbaric but can you keep as
an outside country keep going in and
trying to just fight them or do you have
to arm and give aid to the government in
kabul and it has to do its its own
fighting which i think is probably the
case i don't think there'd be many
british service people who will want to
be going back in to afghanistan and
risking their lives and what would they
achieve would they just delay the
taliban for another year another two
years another five years another 10
years
because certainly those who were
negotiating
in
in
the talks that were held not so long ago
it all appeared rather a bit
and reasonable and talked about have
been very different but it looks like on
the ground there isn't because the metro
is reporting girls as young as 12 being
forced to marry taliban fighters they
have a picture of a refugee girl who's
fed with her parents absolutely
tired
tales of executions it is absolutely
horrific but 20 years was a long time
for the uk us
some other countries to be in that
country doing
lately air cover and training rather
than doing the main fighting but there
were more than 50 british service
personnel lost their lives uh fact the
bill really the 40 billion i'm less
concerned about but those lost lives all
those who have life-changing
injuries how long can you go on and keep
fighting there
if the if the afghanis
who oppose the taliban don't do it
themselves let's try and squeeze this as
well
do you mind i'm just going to say very
briefly we should say as well i think
the death toll for afghani afghanistan
people is unknown but he's put a minimum
120 000 a minimum that's shocking that's
that's the size of quite a large town in
britain wiped out nothing to show for it
yeah indeed so um yeah and more to come
we fear don't we um let's just do two
quick stories if you don't mind one is
the guardian uh which talks about the
cost of self-isolation and homeschooling
uh for councils children's services um
who wants to do that one
oh um and our i will do and it's
absolutely chilling there there's
quite a detailed report going around the
country and just the levels of child
abuse
problems now getting kids fostered
because there are so many people being
taken away from families and it is the
the other side of covid which we've
talked many times saying in terms of
cancelled uh cancer operations which is
really grim and people have lost their
lives because of that but you can also
now just see kids not go kids not going
to school and being in very very unhappy
troubled homes sometimes with violent
parents they're paying a huge price and
whenever we we read here see
reports about the thr uh the danger and
the the pain suffered by kids mentally
you can read about it in the guardian it
is absolutely horrific and just quickly
to um about the oil price us asking opec
to boost output um or else the oil price
increase
harms the recovery andrew
it is talking about in america pretzel
prices have soared 50 in the last few
months biden uh like every other
leader is grappling to get his country
out of the post uh pandemic slump and
soaring petrol prices uh americans drive
a lot of cars and uh petrol is king in
america he's wants opec to uh increase
production to so then the price will
fall um good luck with that president
biden because some petrol prices of
course in this country have been soaring
too and it's going to be a problem it's
going to be it will impact on inflation
which is beginning to worry leaders all
around the world inflation has virtually
been
extinguished from our economies but it's
creeping up and fuel prices will be a
big factor another big exam results day
obviously tomorrow with gcses uh but the
question is what happens to the
education secretary after that andrew
well in my school we used to have
something called the sack race when i
was in the junior school he's going to
get sacked he's useless he's hopeless
he's probably the worst education
secretary we've ever had some people
think it's not his fault but he's dealt
with so many things badly in covid such
as teaching
taking kids all back to school for one
day in january when he'd threatened to
well he was not threatening he was suing
a number of councils uh in december with
public money who were closing schools
early because of the kent varian a
complete shambles from start to finish
and they're one of the biggest losers i
think in covid have been kids the way
their schools have been disrupted exams
have been disrupted i'll chuck kevin's
trade union mates in there too because i
don't think they help much either but
gavin williamson is woefully out of his
depth and if the question is
who replaces him a lot of money on a
woman called kemi badanok she's only
been an mp since 2017. she's feisty
she's very very clever she's she's in
the treasury she's also got the
equalities brief and she's the great
anti-woke warrior or does nadine sahar
who's done a sterling job as vaccines
minister does he get it i suspect it's
the first one kenny okay interesting and
just very quickly on that we love a
reshuffle don't we um and it's been a
while kevin since we've had one
he has he's
johnson has tried to hang on to his old
uh vote leave mates and not ship people
around he he does have a very untalented
cabinet maybe he likes it that way
because the the chancellor hiroshi
sunaku was pretty uh pretty strong
standing now they're at war now aren't
they he was joking or maybe uh slightly
seriously suggesting he was gonna move
him and he's gonna probably have to
promote liz truss who is doing very well
with conservative grassroots members
although i think she's a
bit of a joke when you look at the trade
deal she's supposedly negotiating
brilliant
but williams
williamson should be permanently
excluded that's it i normally think give
other people a chance get pupils back
into school when they're being kicked
out but williamson he just he just lacks
everything you need in that job to see
well
honestly
he's not here to defend himself and i
want to just very quickly in 30 seconds
do the lost story you're not going to
carry on first of all you wanted to do
um the charity boss who lobbied
ministers who now works with uh the
prime minister's wife carrie johnson or
the alpaca cam uh the geronimo story
maybe we've only got time for that
you've got 20 seconds andrew
well kevin wants to save the alpaca i
couldn't care less no i don't want to
say actually it's about gavin williamson
there's talk he might survive because
there's chief whit he knows where all
the bodies have been so what's he going
to tell us boris johnson's been a bit of
a lad in his time is he i think we all
know that gav
okay look i don't know i think the
alpaca should go the way of gavin
williamson if it's tested positive for
tv twice i'm sorry for the owner i'm
sorry for the alpaca but uh that's it
it's uh it's it's gotta go and people
who watch that they won't all the face
of the
okay look your environment secretary
george eustis is saying it has to go
like yes star wars called for it to go
will you keep it will you spread a bit
of tb no you i don't want it i don't
want it they are i appreciate it
job done kevin
kevin mcguire and andrew thank you both
so much indeed see you soon thank you